aristotle writes uh this alone is denied
even to god to make what has been
not to have been
[Music]
[Music]
so first of all why study history comes
from a greek word means
inquiry looking into things
the first book of history was written by
herodotus it's called the histories
it's a story of the past and of course
not everything in the past
significant things in the past things
that we can learn from
things that stand for something it's
just a piece really
of this wish that we have to understand
in his metaphysics aristotle says in the
first line
the human soul stretches itself out to
know
we like to know and one of the things we
like to know is we'd like to know about
ourselves
because unlike other creatures we're not
ruled simply by instinct
we have to choose our way which way
should we go
and then the second thing is we look at
others and we are
unusually well equipped to do this
because we can talk
we can explain things to each other we
can tell each other about our
inmost thoughts so history
just expands the scope and this
the past is the only thing we can study
intensely
the present is fleeting past is fixed
at least according to the old school of
thought
these days uh it's a deconstructionist
age
and uh what we think is we're our own
special time
a development or a progress on previous
times
and that sets up a way to reinterpret
those old times
so that they fit our categories and we
tend to look down on them a bit too
[Music]
that seems to me exactly wrong
aristotle writes uh this alone is denied
even to god to make what has been not to
have been
uh so history it gives us
a fixity that is made up of things that
at the time
were constantly shifting and hard to
estimate
when we're picking what we're going to
do from among various options we always
have two things in mind one is
what would be the right thing to do and
the other is
what is possible to do and you know you
can't always do the purely right thing
well if you go back and study the people
in the past
they're in the same situation and yet
in their case the whole story is known
it's not changing anymore and you can go
back and you can
put yourself in the shoes you know of
winston churchill
or of abraham lincoln those by the way
are two things that are sublime
to do beautiful to do important to do
and you can be with them where lincoln
faces the question
should i let the south go look at the
body count
lincoln grappled with that question you
can grapple with him
churchill should we fight to the death
against hitler
he's offering a deal so the point is
there's a lot to know
and what can you know can you know
it's now right or wrong to do what we're
going to do
in some country where we've had wars no
you can just know
that a serious man had
cautioned about that and what were the
factors that he evaluated to make up his
mind you could look at the same factors
they may be different today
but all of that depends on treating
history
as if it is made by people who although
very different from us
in many ways are yet still people
the the animals that can talk to each
other
learn from each other recognize good and
evil which are all by the way
we have a course on aristotle where we
explain this
those are all related our ability to see
good and evil and our ability to talk
boil down to the same thing
and so a creature like that which lives
in a perishable body
and has needs how does it steer itself
by the ultimate truth
when in its needs it's just like any
animal
well that's the human test and the
people in the past had to go through
that test
good history then will be an
accurate and so far as it's humanly
possible to make it
a picture of what happened in the past
with a sympathy for the people so that
one can learn from them
they made mistakes yeah and
don't we do we live in a perfect world
today
if we don't then they were grappling
with the same thing we are
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn